this Canadian microbrewery only makes
pure rice wine called June my shoe the
rice is milled before it arrives at the
brewery milling removes the proteins and
lipids on the outside layers of the rice
grain first they wash the rice then they
pour it in a porous bag and soak it in
cold filtered water once it reaches the
right consistency they drain the bag
overnight then they pour the rice into a
steamer the steamer cooks the rice under
pressure for about an hour they cover
the steamer with cloth to contain the
rice as it cooks the steamer softens the
rice but doesn't overcook it to ferment
at the right speed the rice needs to be
firm on the outside and soft in the
center workers separate the rice by hand
then use fans to cool the rice down to
about 98 degrees next they transfer it
to a heated room they spread out the
rice and cover it with mold spores
imported from Japan
when heated the spores germinate and
grow on the rice the spores secrete
enzymes that will transform the starch
into fermentable sugars workers insert a
thermometer into the rice then wrap it
in cloth to hold in the heat 48 hours
later the sweet rice called Koji is
ready now they begin the fermentation
process they mix three quarters of
steamed rice with one quarter of Koji in
a temperature controlled fermentation
tank then they add spring water in yeast
the mold enzymes in the coachee convert
the starch in the steamed rice into
sugars the yeast consumes those sugars
and produces alcohol the process takes
about three weeks the brew master checks
the temperature acidity residual sugar
and alcohol levels every day when the
brew is ready they pour it into cloth
bags they neatly stack the bags in a
traditional Japanese mechanical press as
the press fills up the weight of the
bags kick starts depressing they seal
the press with heavy steel plates and
now the pressing mechanism
as they turn the crank the press
squeezes all the liquid out of the backs
when they're done only unfermented rice
will be left behind the liquid saki
drains out of a spout at the base of the
press
they aged the sake and refrigerated
tanks for up to four months the sake
this brewery produces is unpasteurized
this enhances the flavor but requires
refrigeration
you